Joe Biden campaign volunteers are
quitting in droves take a look at this
because of what's going a group of
staffers working on President Joe
Biden's re-election campaign warned the
president that his volunteers are
quitting and droves over his handling of
Israel's military response in the Gaza
Strip Biden has faced immense pressure
from members of his own party over the
US policies in light of the surpriz
homas tech on October 7th you know look
we have uh a lot of people come on the
show are Jewish that may be surprising
to uh for many people who watch to know
well other people think it's too many
people who are Jewish well uh we have
critici both way I think we have 10
times the national average uh uh of
Jewish people je of guests who are
Jewish so it's what someone did a thing
is like it was 21% of our guests are
Jewish or something and I'm like yeah
it's probably because they're abrahamic
conservatives I don't know whatever and
they're prominent social media
personalities or whatever but uh I
literally don't care however we talk to
a lot of these people and it's really
fascinating to hear what they'll say
behind the scenes about their family
members they'll say on the show a lot of
a lot of progressive Jewish individuals
are waking up to what the left is and
what Democrats are doing because of the
the attack on Israel behind the scenes
they'll say the same thing but be a bit
more specific because they don't want to
put their families at risk I can respect
that and they'll say like I got I got an
aunt she's liberal and she came freaking
out like what's going on and I'm like I
told you I'm just imagining all of the
Hanukkah dinners where you had these
liberal Jewish people meeting with their
conservative relatives and the conserva
like we told you this was going on and
you didn't believe us and now they do
and now you take a look what's going on
with Joe Biden's campaign this split is
insane Joe Biden is losing staff members
because he won't support Hamas but who
are they're they're not staff members I
mean they might be paid but it's they're
saying volunteers which prob probably
people who are volunteering in their
early 20s mid 20s maybe up until early
30s and that group of progressive
liberal people tend to be very anti- not
even leftist and so it's interesting
because it's actually a huge age divide
that's what I think think the Democratic
party is starting to realize that the
older members basically the Boomer
Democrats have a very different position
on this this International issue than
their younger cohorts so instead of it
being like yes come come take this
position volunteer a third batch may
have just dropped right right now within
the past few minutes that's why you see
such an uh an outsized influence of
those of that discussion on social media
now why when you look at comment
sections on Instagram it's all free
Palestine and and Tik Tok right this is
what we heard over and over again that
you know the mainstream media might be
presenting a more pro-israel present
presentation but Tik Tok was
predominantly Pro Palestine it was Jen's
ears do love Osama Bin Laden what AED
that on 2023 but it was actually the
media that blew that up that story cuz
like it was only like a few people who
had it was like Tik Tac it was like only
like few million and then the media
talked about it and next thing you know
it blew up to like billions of views
yeah it's a I mean a few million is
still a lot to me yeah I know say but
compared Tik Tok views that's like the
uh like right now you're seeing a a live
Fe just we've had however many decades
of colleges that have told you that the
place that you were born from is evil
and that your ancestry is evil and all
of those things that your Progressive
and leftist professors have
indoctrinated into the previous
generations is finally coming to pass as
the new generation hits all of these
problems in society right now there's no
love of old Americana or what this
country used to be there's no sense of
identity here anymore and all they're
left with is a deep burning hatred for
this country yeah and a lot of allies
not surprising that Joe Biden is losing
his young volunteers and I'm presuming
they're young I haven't read all his AR
I guarantee you they're they're on the
younger side the same way that Harvard
is losing its older billionaire donors
who are saying the things that you're
teaching the students the the positions
the students are taking are in congruous
with my views and I no longer want to
support you financially the thing that
young people have to offer any sort of
influential campaign is their time and
and their energy it's not the
billionaire donor that's out knocking on
doors although they contribute in a
different way their financial
contribution means a lot to Harvard but
political campaigns need the young
people yeah and so I mean I think it's
good right it's not that I like conflict
it's that I like this party having to
reckon with itself that it is saying one
thing like it bothers me a lot that
people always like the Republican part
is about to fall apart and it's crazy
and in my position you know I think
conservative movements have lots of
different parts that occasionally make
basically become allies at times on
certain issues whereas Democrats tend to
be very lock step you believe these
things but they no longer realize that
they are the party that is preaching
things that the older leadership doesn't
believe in it's interesting to see them
fall apart in front of our eyes well we
saw that starting with when AOC got
elected and when a lot of these younger
progressives got elected right that
there was great divides but she kind of
ended up being more of a she fell along
party lines and a lot of issues
eventually the fact that she voted for
the Ukrainian Aid you're supposed to be
a progressive yeah like at least Thom
Thomas Massie didn't even vote for that
yeah but mass is really interesting
because he's ultimately principled he
has certain things that he believes in
and he will not back down but that's
when I think you lost the progressives
right there the minute they said yes to
this and they said that we're never
going to fund any war no matter how
strong their allies are or how fake our
allies are with them we're not supposed
to be funding this Wars we have to be
like we have to fund Healthcare we have
to fund this and then all of a sudden
you started seeing like they voted no
problems they didn't even like use that
as a bargaining chip like they did with
the bill back better like were using
that over Nancy Pelosi's head that's why
it was never been able to pass and then
it took a while that like had to come
back and then Joe Mansion got involved
and all that so the fact that they
didn't use that over the NY pel's head
that was really telling about the
progressives so I think now they're
using this to show to like bring back
the power that he once had but then it
comes to the fact that like what is your
principle are you for the war or you're
against the war like what are you
exactly for like it's a lot of I think
you look at a story like
this and this is It's the year has only
just begun and I see two things from
this the first is yo we are winning by a
lot you know with with the uh uh the
purchase of of X the boycott of these
big companies the organizational power
of the anti-establishment and the pro
constitutional republic uh uh faction is
tremendous and seeing more and more
victories every single day and then you
see that Joe Biden's volunteers are
quitting over an ideological split the
Democrats are fractured they're falling
apart we already gone through years of
the viral story Democrat quits party how
many times did we see a story like that
remember when they were calling into CNN
being like I am quitting I will never
vote Democrat again no no this was last
like a year no but say like every time
there's a war going on they always say
I'm going to quit the Democratic party
do they really do and they do and so in
the past few years you had that Viral
story where they were calling in a cpan
complaining about what Joe Biden had
been doing what Dem yeah it was crazy
and and it goes viral we get more and
more of that now we've got you know
every couple of months
Democrat quits and switches to the
Republican party now Joe Biden can't
even keep volunteers on because they're
far-left extremists it's kind of
fascinating if you think about it
because a lot of this is fueled by uh
foreign interference using social media
manipulation and I love how the left
claimed that for so long over Trump but
the reality is it's targeting them they
always project you get these apps that
are advocating for Hamas and then these
young people become pramas and then all
of a sudden they quit Joe Biden's
campaign creating a direct
like probability of Americans uniting
around actual American values so if all
of these young people are being
subverted into supporting things like
Hamas but it's not the majority all that
will happen is these people have no
political power America will prevail the
constitutional republic will prevail
Donald Trump will get elected but are
they really like going back are they
really supporting Hamas or they are they
really trying to like support the
Palestinian cause like the Palestinian
people so they are Hamas Hamas yeah look
a week here talk about all the people
who are like Pro Palestine I am
specifically referring to people who are
proas why why am I referring to them
because they in New York were marching
around chanting and for Hamas and
calling them
Heroes well okay I get what your point
but I'm saying when they had rallies in
New York over talk about like the
rallies or you talk about people who are
when they had rallies in New York and
and you know several hundred people show
up the speakers at this event would get
up and say the Freedom Fighters fired
5,000 Rockets Landing in Tel Aviv and
they all clap cheer and scream so those
are pro Hamas protesters in New York
City okay sure if you want to argue that
there is an individual on social media
who's not who doesn't like Hamas and not
pro palese I know many of them I'm not
talking about them you're you're allowed
to be Pro Palestine but the problem is
these most of these people are calling
Hamas Freedom Fighters okay that's why
they're
Med and the idea is that it it it will
uniquely leech votes from the Democrats
as soon assuming that they don't end up
just following in falling in line when
the next election comes cuz a lot of
them do right like as much as CU they
hate it they end up following falling
line vote blue no matter who doesn't
really matter but used to at least used
the hope would be that they're so
ideologically inclined that for once
they won't just end up voting on party
lines because they actually have a
problem with the they actually do
support Hamas but did you see the recent
USA Today poll they said young voters
younger than me younger than 35 Trump
leads by like about two or three points
and that's really shocking I always I
always thought that like you know
between 20 and 30s you're going to vote
blue because you're like so lost until
you start paying taxes and you're like
holy crap I got to vote Republican
because I cannot anymore like the
Democrat Party so you're wondering like
these gen Z's like a lot of them are
crazy but a lot of them are actually
waking up yeah I think they're very
divided is I think that you'll have uh
there'll be an extreme generation where
some people sit very far one end of the
political and ideological spectrum and
some people end up sitting unfortunately
extremely far on the other side and so I
I think that it's it's sort of like when
you talk about the economy you have the
disappearing middle class I think there
is a The Disappearing moderate class of
gen Z and you know the question would be
are they able to reconcile or do they
ultimately meet on the other end of the
political horseshoe and their Norms that
we would view as extreme the things that
they agree on are are out of the box
we're not going to expect them yeah also
be very very first of all be very very
careful of any polls that are conducted
this early in in the election season no
but it's D telling I always think of it
as like a quiz but also like be very
careful because what happens a lot of
time is if they start projecting that
Trump is super far ahead then people get
complacent and they think I don't have
to go out and vote so I'm not going to
so don't lose if you know depending on
what your thoughts on voting are if
you're really really Pro Trump whatever
it is don't allow that to make you
complacent because I do think a lot of
times they end up doing that I mean
theoretically it would I mean I wish I
don't think it's the case it would fuel
a sort of down ticket Sprint where
people are saying well I know exactly
who I want to vote for even if he's
ahead who else do I care about who do I
care about on the state level who do I
care about representing me in the senate
in Congress you know who who is my
Governor because you feel like you've
locked up one office that shouldn't be
enough I don't think this is actually
how voters operate I this is my uh my
idealistic worldview that you if you
feel like well I definitely know who's
going to be president you want to send
them into their term with strong support
both in the in Congress and in the
states uh but going we'll see but going
back what you said like you said be
careful but maybe you never know maybe
they to say they want to vote for Trump
so they could get rid of Biden and put
somebody like Gavin Newsome a younger a
younger Democrat you never know that
could be telling that's why I say I
always think of these polls as quiz and
then like the then when you start going
into the all these votings I think of it
like all the delegates are like the
midterms like the midterm like when you
take a test in college and then to the
general election that's your final
that's how I see it so when people are
like writing off the polls I'm like no
gotta be careful these polls are
doelling also was that a nation was that
done Nation wide was that done the USA
said it wasde nationwide okay I think
but it was telling like um Joe Biden's
losing support by blacks by 25 points
from like 2020 he's losing Hispanics
Trump is leading with Hispanics young
voters and Trump's gaining and all and
he's gaining so like he went like Biden
went from like 80 to
60 but do you think that's people who
would you know part of it is are are
what I'm curious to see is if there's a
a large number of Voters who sit out
this election like what is voter turn
I think the young ones are if it's going
to be Biden so I'm thinking that's like
CU just because they're not voting for
Biden doesn't mean that they're
nationally gained by Trump yes remember
a lot of people sat out 2016 because
they said like I don't like Trump or
Hillary I'm just sitting this one out
but the same thing in 2020 they they sat
out too but I'm saying more yeah 90 more
that's the saying these polls can be
telling as a way of like trying to push
Biden out Donald Trump is uh in swing
States winning amongst people who did
not vote in 2020 by double digit margin
some up to 40% that's what I'm saying
like these polls could be telling push
them out in Michigan they PLL people who
did not vote in 2020 and Trump has a 40%
lead so he's like it's like 60 you know
30 or something C and the whole thing
going back at the Hamas War like um be
6020 the the Israel war like Trump is
leading with the Arab American votes and
like the Republican Party cannot take
that for granted they have to understand
both sides of it it cannot be all 100%
pro Israel they I think the Republican
party is much more tolerant of different
views I think the Democrats are way way
more out each other's thr Trump is very
um for both sides but you see look at
the debate stage they're both like the
Sansa between the sanses and Haley
they're both graveling between trying to
get like the Israeli and APAC you know
endorsements they're more worried about
that than they're worried about the
American people but that's because
they're so far behind in the polls I
mean it do it almost doesn't matter what
they're trying to do because ultimately
the popular vote indicates that they
support Trump and Trump is taking a
position that is attempting to be mod
which also Joe Biden has attempted to be
moderate on the issue and it's failed
because people don't trust him but I'm
saying but like going if the first time
ever this poll has with Arab American
community and Trump is leading and
remember they try to push that whole
Muslim band and they try to like
everything with Trump the fact that he
what the Muslim band what was that the
whole like they were trying to like like
if you look going back to Michigan
that's a heavily populated area of Arabs
and Trump is leading and and that's what
Dearborne dear board but what what what
Muslim ban you the Muslim ban they try
to push that against like um they try to
P who Tred to push it they were trying
to the media they remember the first
you're saying the media was lying about
Trump claiming he wanted a mus right
right so that's the one thing when you
comes to Arabs and Muslims that they
that's the one thing they just don't
like about Trump but they love
everything about his economic polies and
stuff like that but when it came to like
Israel like even though he was very
Trump was very pro-israel he did have
understanding of working his first the
first country he visited diplomatic was
so Arabia yeah so Accords yeah yeah and
he worked on that so but the fact that
the Republican party is Tak it for
granted and they're only picking one
side and they're groeling and then
you're saying like yeah well they're
behind the poles look at like the santis
he's like bashing I just think that
Republicans take a third side which is
to say that they don't really want to
have an interventionist position at all
there are a lot of Republicans they
sound like bush in the the base stage
they sound like Bush Jr or Dick Cheney
with three in hells and lipstick so it
just reminds me like the Republican
party and even like the RNC like they
have no FS given about the minority and
the people the color people who are
choosing to be Republicans because they
only want to pick the side that they're
used to the whole establishment that's
what I'm saying we have to be careful
with this like the polls are T but
Republicans they're very known for
up I always say that like I
mean this is again why I think it's
interesting that there are so many
Republicans right now who you know
theoretically they could be divided they
could say I support this side of that
war I support this side of the war but
there are a fair number of them who are
like the thing is our Focus has to be
domestic our first Focus has to be on
what's going home and I don't really
hear a similar echo in the Democratic
party it might be there and just not
might not be as loud Republicans have a
a another position to take that is not
available to democratic uh politicians
right now Democratic politicians have to
pick a side that's what their voters
want whereas if you're a republican
voter and you know maybe you feel real L
about one side maybe feel strongly about
the other if you have a republican
saying well obviously this is a big
conflict there's a lot going on there
but my priority is to secure our but
there is this like we need to F Israel
we need to make sure we need to
eliminate them like this is water of
combat like and then you have the S is
insulting Arabs which is now you to like
triggering me and like you're losing
people's respect and like he shouldn't
be talking like talk about like Arabs
wearing man dresses I wouldn't be
talking when you're wearing three in ch
boy and you're down the poll by 55
points yeah and you're trying to like
catch up with a girl think who's like a
Alibaba version of Hillary Clinton but
do you think like for minority voters
that are joining the Republican party or
who are likely to support a republican
candidate at this time do you think uh
they are looking for candidates who
support a certain side of the war or
would they be would an America First
Position first it has to be America
First agenda the only reason why they
want to come to this country he also
does need to bring up the Abraham
Accords a lot like I think a good amount
because you're going to the people who
are voting America First are going to be
all in on your domestic policy if you're
putting you know if it's talking about
closing the border and and Shoring up
things there right sure but right now
with International conflict being such a
big part of the story uh pushing them to
see that there was a time not that long
ago when we did have a more stable you
know world for yeah like I think but we
have the Republican parties on the stage
pushing to fund a country that has a
budget surplus when we're running a
budget deficit and we can't even keep up
we just hit 34 trilon we just hit 34
trillion yesterday and we're growing
everybody allbody here owes
$105,000 in debt for what I didn't pay
for that for college I didn't own that
for my mortgage but I got to pay that
for for some War so is Israel's got a
budget surplus yes what's do you know
what it is I mean their budget surplus
their GDP is about 4% a year and we're
fund their military we fund three what
3.8 billion a year they run a budg of
surplus in between two Wars right now
the American people for the first time
in 35 years as of January of 2023 uh
Israel posts a budget surplus driven by
higher tax revenue so what are they
looking at they're like 2.8 uh a budget
surplus of $2.85 billion how much do we
give them 3.8 so they actually they're
run they could cover a good portion of
that this point yeah so but we want to
get the 14 billion and like right now we
have like no
money they're like you can pay a little
bit more of taxes can't you you can go
ahead and we're going to have to pay
taxes what I'm saying ta they're they're
they have no the American politicians
have no problem bleeding us dry right so
they they don't have a problem with that
and that's an issue right now the fact
that they want to tie to the Border they
want to tie to border security and I'm
sick and tired of these Republicans
running and trekking down to the
southern border check your ass back to
the capital right now and get something
done thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at
timcast.net membersonly shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next
time